moi ce qui m'a choqué c'est
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement il ya un
discours
qui prolifèrent à travers les canaux
médiatiques stigmatisons les quartiers
thing directeur du site et un mois
malheureusement par rapport aux actions
sur ça que je ne m'étends pas sur le
territoire national
car à ce jour j'ai visité plus de 50
villes en comptait plus de trente mille
personnes j'ai été beaucoup diabolisé
par rapport ce genre de discours où on
en a marre à monsieur mois des policiers
cagoulés armés j'ai fait plutôt de 2,25
pas sa façade les magistrats du siège
encore gisement l'asi 13 ce 13 mai j'ai
un jugement le 23 mai j'ai un jugement
le 30 mai à des jugements mail et tout
cela pour quoi pour crier haut et fort
ce sont des français à part entière on a
le droit à la dignité alors je vous
remercie alors moi justement si j'ai
parlé de la france qui devient un far
west et parce que avant c'est vrai qu'on
entendait quand même beaucoup de choses
dans des banlieues et tout ça la gdd des
exemples de choses qui se passent dans
le métro dans le vert dans le 7e
arrondissement moi c'est un sentiment
d'insécurité et d'un tuba la france soit
dans ses déplacements des gens qui
commettent des délits d infraction ou
autre mais dire que la presse est à far
west indirectement il ya une connotation
les quartiers et les cités et les
banlieues
excusez moi je n'ai pas vraiment pas
pensé à ça j'ai pensé à ce jeu et je
pense au far-west parce que ça se
généralise et que c'est partout note
mais moi je me sens en indiquant mais je
sais pas le reportage comme darmon
bizarrement les gaumont on a vécu des
quartiers du sud de la france et l
attaque à la machette et pas longtemps
et c'est un fait dans le 7ème à paris
non plus mais ils auront regarde aussi
ce qui se passe en permanence si on a
les infos monsieur je crois juste mais
enfin je ne sais pas pareil on regarde
les infos et on s'y remet juste de
commenter pendant que après le match
aurait dû récolter des fois je suis
d'accord avec adama sur un truc c'est
que sur jeux à la télévision et ça c'est
la meilleur de soi ici c'est
insupportable quand vous regardez ce qui
si ce qui les reportages sur les sites
et sur les banlieues une impression que
toute la journée il n'y a que des
méfaits qui sont réalisés alors que je
vous le dis j'ai un des lilas et j'ai
passé mon enfance là bas mon père il
était encore
franchement y les gens vivent sont très
contents d'être con tre inactifs ils
vivent tous ensemble il ya plein de
jeunes surtout se lire comme john qui
aide qui est vraiment qui est vraiment
des personnes âgées qui est ça jamais
personne mon nom mais surtout sur mes
gars série mais où dans le monde à
calama chaîne sur un parking où ça on va
mr tous les mois ce qui me désole là on
a l'exemple typique il prend un fait
divers sortie de son contexte il va
mais aujourd'hui les premières victimes
de cette de ses coups de machette ces
personnes qui habitent dans ces milieux
là qu'elles sont un village ou dans une
cité et des risques et des violences
dans les quatre coins de la france il
peut y avoir il peut y avoir des
violences avec armes à feu peut avoir
des violences avec arme et apporte mais
aujourd'hui nous ensemble de réfléchir
comment voir un discours cohérent
possède sortir tous la tête vers le haut
1 aujourd'hui jouer sur des métiers qui
peuvent pas ce qui peut se passer en
tire une généralité stigmatiser des
quartiers les cités faire en sorte que
les quartiers
dans le 7e arrondissement
absolument car les bagnoles et katia
surnomment ses c'est une erreur que je
veux dire à monsieur c'est que pour
trouver des solutions il faut d'abord
avoir peut-être l'honnêteté d'accepter
de dire effectivement oui ce qui se
passe là bas ne sont pas en nombre ce
qui est des zones interdites ou des
trucs sur la banlieue qu'on dit c'est ça
il ya des mecs géniaux qui bossent oui
mais c'est pas ça ici ben voilà nommé
aujourd'hui contraire banon mais bien de
dire que c'est des faits à part ban ou
quand on aime la télé qu'on veut
absolument me souviens des squatteurs d
attaquer ce match est de la danse n'est
machin mais ça je mettrai à notre
demande à mathieu oui ce jeu je pourrais
pas mais je vous appelle vous appeler
monsieur nombre de mondial je vous ai
dit que c'est des faits divers où ces
dérives qui peuvent y aller il piquait
peuvent y arriver les premières victimes
c'est ce qu'ils habitent moi j'habite
d'osaka d'identité on est souvent les 3
me oui à plus de 20000 habitants mais ce
mot ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai vécu dans
ma vie je pense qu'à cause d'eux mêmes
faits divers mais
monsieur je vous dis moi j'ai redit
d'insultés dans un quartier gérant d'une
société qui s'appelle cadel killer de
flics j'ai vécu des choses ne se prenait
pas imaginer moi quand je vais ici ce
bromont pour ces dates appeler madame
budget que faire des généralités
indirectement m'attends à directement
j'ai pas dit que vous avez dit que dans
les quartiers dans des cités c'est le
faro et scout et malheureusement avec le
discours ambiant qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui dans nos canaux médiatiques
par des politiques et par des médias
c'est que indirects manquant pas
d'incivilités lorsqu'on parle de risque
automatiquement on stigmatise des jeunes
de quartiers notamment des jeunes issus
d'origines étrangères on va dire
subsaharienne est d'origine berbère
aujourd'hui gilles verdez vous n'êtes
pas la corrida n'y a pas du tout c'est
inadmissible et en fait tous les
chiffres tous les chiffres disent le
daniel s'ajuste il va plus vite
aujourd'hui les bennes sont plus lourdes
les peines de prison les vols violents
ont diminué considérablement entre 2010
et 2020 de course en 2010 2009 en
écouter un peu 2010 2020 voire 2% donc
série ça n'a aucun sens et effectivement
c'est stigmatiser des endroits
particuliers parce que dès qu'on dit far
west on entend pour lyon
mais avec un ton méprisant la ouais mais
soutient que c'est la france et c'est la
faulx dont on doit s'occuper rejoint une
chaire de loganair ce
qui passait là bas que ça se passe
les attaques à la machette
juste précisément ça veut dire quoi
là-bas déjà parce que déjà 2 que là-bas
déjà il ya un air assez condescendant la
tombe vous
expliquer pourquoi j'ai mis en place la
révolution est en marche mais supposer
qu'ils sont hyper centre comment ça
c'est que dans nos quartiers dans nos
cités ne sont pas prêts à la violence
alors que nos parents nous ont très bien
éduqué mais ce comment ça se fait que
dans nos quartiers de nos cités on n'est
pas impliqué dans tout ce qui est la
chose politique et mais en 2016 d'une
réflexion ce avec des amis proches
rivales et on la met en passe la
révolution est en marche une révolution
philosophique car l'amour de la sagesse
peut que ramener à la paix de la même si
j'ai tendu la main aux actions
policières à la chose politique au final
mon côté je dois on m'a diabolisé à
l'étape et adama touré tour google zèle
à avoir peur peut être mais non ce n'est
pas lui qui était à côté de moi elle est
là la réalité monsieur à qui profite le
crime cependant cette question
[Rires]
[Musique]
s
il appelait
en
[Rires]
avant-soirée
me
suis dit que c'était des faits divers
les intérêts à la machette etc mais en
fait quand les faits divers se
multiplient çà devient un vrai phénomène
de société la la la violence rajeuni
elle devient de plus en plus forte et en
fait ce qu a dit daniel c'était pas du
tout ce que ce que vous avez compris
stigmatiser les quartiers au contraire à
la 10 la france devient le favori c'est
à dire une généralisation de la ctu
messi ni moi ce que je reprocherais dans
la situation c'est que l'état est fort
avec les faire est faible avec les forts
on le voit partout ils verbalisent des
gens qui sont sur une plage sans masque
pendant le film en est à côté de ça il
ya les dealers en bas et je suis
d'accord avec vous que les premières
victimes sont les riverains les gens qui
doivent subir ça au quotidien qu'ils
sont intimidés et c'est scandaleux il
faut que ça s'arrête il faut que l'état
soit fort fort avec les forts et faibles
a fait l'effet de ces photos vous dites
pourquoi l'at on est là on enfin mais
non bien sûr dit la bête moi je
[Rires]
madame j'étais un capitaliste du ghetto
de 14 à 30 ans ce qui m'a amené à
réfléchir à dire comment je suis ainsi
jusqu'à preuve du contraire dans le
quartier de lost est ce que ce que vous
venez de décrire en respectant
l'environnement lorsqu'il ya des
personnes qui arrivent et toutes ces
tares on essaie de faire en sorte que
dont le crime et qu'on combat tiens ça
soit kahn n'y a pas de désordre et tout
c'est madame salle et dans les quartiers
sud est ce qui s'appelle les les choufs
les gens qui vont siffler lorsqu'il
précise arrive lorsqu'il siffler en une
seconde matin à dire deux secondes y'a
plus personne c'est désert les policiers
ils ont ils ont roulis dont cartier
libre au moment des discours qui sont
tenues à travers les canaux médiatiques
que vous portez ces biens
n'ont rapporté quand on vous dit que
l'état il est fort avec les faibles et
faible avec les forts alors que sam
adams et foca aujourd'hui - au jour
d'aujourd'hui je vous démontre le
contraire le vrai problème qu'on a dans
nos quartiers c'est vraiment de donner
l'opportunité à des personnes qui
portent des projets sociaux des
personnes qui attend pas des personnes
qui valoir pas à pas à joindre les deux
bouts genre donner les moyens de les
traiter
de sujets dits
doux le far west et ya effectivement
pourquoi maintenant parce qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui fait que beaucoup de
personnes sur violente qu'est ce que
c'est que beaucoup de personnes qui
pensent que la violence peut peuvent
leur ramenait
pas forcément très violent qu'est ce qui
fait que parce qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement beaucoup de personnes se
disent que si ils vont pas vers eux un
homme appelle ça nous l'amour du risque
ne pense jamais pouvoir seulement besoin
de leurs familles et nous l'idée on a
vraiment envie c'était de changer cette
image là car dans les catégories ce
thème a dans son bas de 1% voire 1% il
ya 99 autres personnes qui habitent en
saison passée c'est ce qu'elle a des qui
sont victimes c'est exactement ce que
cherche et on va comporter des
spectateurs merci oui oh tiens merci oui
mais pour cent